look at some of the [ __ ] you were asking
me to make you as a kid ray guns a whip
that forces people to like you
invisibility cuffs a Parent Trap a
lightning gun a teddy bear with
anatomically correct innards
night-vision googly eye glasses sound
erasing sneakers false fingerprints fall
asleep darts a lie detecting doll an
indestructible baseball bats a Taser
shaped like a ladybug a fake police
badge location tracking stickers rainbow
colored duct tape mind controlled hair
clips poison gum a pink sentient
switchblade hey everybody this is gonna
be my episode 9 Easter Egg video there
were a whole bunch of questions they
raised at the end like it was sort of
left hanging so I'll try to answer what
my takeaway was based on that final
moment in that post-credit scene so if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get everything I do
Rick and Morty every week and even
though next week is the final episode
I'll still be doing weekly rick and
morty during the offseason and i'll talk
a little bit about season four too but
the title of the episode was the abc's
of Beth of sort of a play on the idea of
the ABCs of death that horror anthology
series as well as best childhood they
sort of implied that she was this
murderous psychopath but really like
that montage of all the crazy toys in
the sentient night that she asked Rick
to make for her which is sort of a cry
for help and she just didn't know how to
make friends that well she had
abandonment issues and I think by his
own admission Rick was not a great dad
so he would just make her those things
to make her go away like oh you want a
sentient knife here you go why don't you
go off and play with it because I'm busy
and then he also implied that he had to
make a couple of clones and it got to be
a big problem then he created fruit peel
and to sort of keep her busy while he
was doing other things so I think Beth
had a great arc in this episode she
comes to the realization that she's her
father's daughter the apple doesn't fall
far from the tree
Rick concludes that she's very smart she
should just go put a saddle on the
universe just go out and have some fun I
can make a clone of you there'd be no
consequences no chance of Blade Runner
and I'll actually I'll bring that up at
the end too because I think they might
be lengths on evil more to Easter eggs
too so in my feet a
bunch of you were asking did Beth choose
the clone or did she choose to stay and
just based on the way she does a
complete 180 in his hugging rig and
everything seems so nice it just feels
way too easy like the real Beth wouldn't
look this refreshed like she would
actually be pretty tired like she's
cleaned herself up after she took care
of Tommy they made the clone and dropped
him off she would still be a little bit
sad about some of the things she learned
about herself during the episode so when
it seems like everything's back to
normal
everything's perfect just like a sitcom
it almost feels too good to be true so
that's why I think that she's a clone in
this instance here but the thing to
remember about that it's not that big of
a twist because even c-137 rick says
you're not my daughter so in so many
words rick is saying that all rick's
love all of their beds but also at the
same time reality doesn't really matter
so that's why you should just go out and
just have some fun no consequences
Rick even created more tea and summer
robots in a previous episode to fool
Beth so how would creating a fake
version of be any different from that
[Music]
but then over in Jerry's storyline you
have that blue alien that he's been
having sex with a sort of a rebound for
Beth she's sort of a mixture of Liara
from Mass Effect just with the way her
head looks and her blue skin and that
tattoo on her face chitara from
Thundercats as Jerry says as well as the
three boobed alien from Total Recall the
aliens that she's fighting throughout
the episode seem kind of like predators
with the way their mouths open up like
that but the whole Farooqi land thing
it's just stupid funny and kind of gross
at the same time when you find out what
Tommy has done to stay alive
there were a lot of you asking about why
Rick's armed when it got bitten off
wasn't cybernetic because we got the
scan of him during the Jerry episode if
you remember after that episode during
the toxic Rick episode he grew himself a
new body so at the beginning of this
episode as far as we know he has a
completely organic body all of the Tommy
stuff was a little bit of a play on Game
of Thrones as well as the play within
the play with in Game of Thrones like
Arya's play from season 6 so if you
couldn't tell
the guest actor that was playing Tommy
was Thomas Middleditch from Silicon
Valley I feel like he had the perfect
voice for that Joffrey type character so
the idea that he's gone completely crazy
is a little understandable but obviously
they're making fun of a lot of the
incest on Game of Thrones with a little
bit of cannibalism thrown in there
but if you don't remember from Game of
Thrones Season six Arya watches a play
where they sort of tell the history of
the first couple seasons of the show
where you see all the things happened
during season 1 season 2 season 3 up to
the red wedding so that's kind of the
parody they're doing with Tommy's
version of the play which Rick then
certifies fresh on Rotten Tomatoes
certified fresh but probably one of the
smartest jokes that they had in the
episode and most self parodying was when
the writers made fun of themselves by
saying there's a couple things that an
adventurer needs to be good conflict
steaks a way for me to benefit and
clearly more tea so that's really the
writers making fun of their alternate
types of stories like this where Morty
isn't in the a story like Beth and Rick
are the a story for this week mr.
goldenfold's math class was amazing and
you kind of wonder if maybe he doesn't
know math so well either
one [ __ ] plus two [ __ ] equals a
bunch of [ __ ] and then you look on
the blackboard behind him and it says 3
plus 3 equals question mark like he's
not sure what the answer is and you look
at some of the other kids in Morty's
class there were a couple of weird
Easter eggs in here too but you look in
the back here and you see this kid that
looks kind of like he's in his 40s or
something like that
you may have spotted that there is a mr.
poopy butthole in this reality you see
him on the fridge in this picture with
Rick we don't know where he is in
present day but he's alive somewhere in
this reality and then there are a couple
meta fourth wall breaks so Rick sings
doo doo in my but the song then Justin
roiland sings that in his normal singing
voice over the episode while they're
doing the montage cloning Tommy doo doo
bud doo doo doo doo doo bud
I don't know what to do he's a spy blow
him up I'm gonna go take a [ __ ] then I
sort of consider the answering machine
joke at the end a bit of a fourth-wall
break too because justin roiland says
nobody really uses these except for
exposition but the last one is a bit of
a metaphor wall break for the fans that
are always guessing about time travel
when he goes to get the pizzas and then
sort of turns and says by the way that
wasn't time travel I just grabbed some
pizzas on the other side of the portal
so really like the only other big easter
egg is when Morty says you're a
delivered in ex machina time to take it
and they all run away that's basically
like the blue alien coming out of
nowhere the male 3 boobed
alien so the resolution of that story
wasn't that great but the way Beth sort
of came to the realization of what she
was really like like she's really honest
with herself Jerry had to do the same
thing so that was sort of his version of
that journey but Rick did mention his
wife during the episode without actually
giving any real answers about her I did
a separate video sort of speculating
based on fruit peel and and Beth's
backstory that we know so I'll link that
video at the end of this but let me know
in the comments if you spotted any other
Easter eggs or references that I didn't
include in the video it what'll happen
is is I'll do my finale trailer video
tomorrow and then I'll talk a little bit
about season four so there is a new
round of that merch giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video
congratulations to the winner from the
last video gangrene gang please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details I'll
just name the next winner when I post
that next Rick and Morty video you can
click here to learn all about Rick's
wife and you can click here to start
getting ready for flash season 4 thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]